kunst trifft auf industriedenkmal die
ehemalige eisenhütten in völklingen ist
eine ideale kulisse für den 8 allein auf
der außenanlage haben 20 künstler ihre
werke installiert diesen schornstein hat
sich der künstler mambo ausgesucht er
lebt in los angeles und hat schon in den
1980 er jahren street art gemacht heute
ist er ein etablierter künstler
er arbeitet schon lange nicht mehr mit
der spraydose sondern mit dem pinsel die
adrenalinausschüttung beim illegalen
malen kann süchtig machen
das war wie eine dose jetzt fokussiere
ich mich mehr auf den stil den ausdruck
und mein eigenes vokabular das ist eine
andere arbeit
es ist eine studioarbeit aber ich fühle
mich mehr als künstler
ich muss nichts illegales wir machen
gleich mehrere werke wurden von den
berliner künstlern mental gassi
angebracht sie haben autoren gittern und
silos menschen porträtiert die heute in
der völklinger hütte arbeiten in ihrem
berliner studio werden die fotos im
riesenformat ausgedruckt die künstler
arbeiten schon seit 20 jahren in den
straßen verschiedener städte weltweit
häufig natürlich ohne erlaubnis nun sind
sie bei der erben art biennale
eingeladen das gelände zu bespielen wir
suchen immer nach objekten oder
architektouren die dreidimensional sind
oder zumindest irgendwie eine tiefe
haben oder irgendwie in den raum rein
gehen damit wir nicht nur ein planes
bild ein kleines porträt abbilden können
sondern eben eigentlich eine foto
skulptur erschaffen können
eine der porträtierten ist hendrik
kerstens abgelichtet das wohl von allen
seiten oben unten und musste übelste
grimassen schneiden dann wurde
entschieden super den nehmen wir
und ja das hatte ich mich dann hier
wieder hin da diese art von fotografie
doch ziemlich mörderisch ist
wasseroberflächen haut und so weiter
angeht sind die damen nicht weiters
kritischer als unter einer aber ich
glaube sie kann damit leben
auch der künstler martino aus frankreich
klebt eine kunst
er hat sich ein häuschen dass arbeiter
früher für pausen genutzt haben
ausgesucht und deutsche plakate aus den
1970 er jahren zum thema
arbeitssicherheit künstlerisch
bearbeitet
[Musik]
ich arbeite mit kleinen bildern die ich
durch ein faxgerät schicke damit sie
stärker gepixelt sind dann male ich
davon eine größere fassung am ende
versehe ich die bilder mit knalligen
signalfarben in der gewaltigen kulisse
der sogenannten müller halle dort wo
früher die rohstoffe des eisenbergs
gelagert wurden sind rund 100 weitere
werke der urban art aus 20 ländern zu
sehen
es ist straßenkunst die nun auf leinwand
gelandet ist
[Musik]
die abend ist die kunst die als street
art von der straße kommt am anfang sind
diese künstlerinnen und künstler als
besitzstörung verhaftet und ins
gefängnis gesperrt worden
und irgendwann gab es dann den punkt wo
diese künstler aus dem straßenraum
heraus auf bewegliche gründe
bilder skulpturen gefertigt haben das
ist der beginn unserer art biennale und
seitdem zeigen wir diese kunst die sich
da aufgemacht hat auch als neue kultur
richtung richtung museum die erben art
biennale in völklingen zeigt dass
inzwischen viele ehemalige
straßenkünstler auf dem weg sind sich
einen sicheren platz auf dem kunstmarkt
zu ermahnen